après compile complice on s'immisce chez
les extrémistes avec christophe
bourseiller une taupe chez les gluck
christophe conseiller du travail à paris
match entre autres à 7 apparaît surtout
enfin tu as commencé très jeune une
carrière cinématographique
avec la guerre des boutons où il ya
quatre ans avec quatre hommes s'est dit
mort qu'est ce que disait je disais
uniquement couille molle est un mot qui
est resté passe quelque chose qu'on voit
pas ce que voulait dire
enfin j'ai été très bien payé puisqu'il
problème à payer qu'une petite voiture
que je n'ai plus malheureusement j'ai
perdu a enchaîné avec trois godard tout
ça tranquillement pas monsieur arrêtez
vous faire mes études
ouais quand même je voulais faire un peu
de philo ça va intéresser et j'ai repris
juste après quoi
et après yves robert a questionné des
gens disaient plusieurs où il avait une
phrase très c'est lille et j'aime vos
simple voilà très bien faire de la radio
qu'est ce que j'ai fait ou avril oui je
fais pas mal de radio puisque ce matin
la radio café de la télé tu as fait jour
j oui merci en main et puis alors par un
côté archiviste par exemple taëf et des
disques ça fait brouillage a dit
s'appeler brouilla 2 2 2 mais s'étaient
tous les meilleurs moments de la fm vous
avez dit ça c'est à dire que si tu veux
je
soit un peu fou parce que lorsque les
radios libres sont arrivés j'avais une
petite mini casse est branché sur
marrakech et j'enregistrais tout gérer
le chaplin radio libre je l'enregistré
et puis un jeu une phase de reflux que
j'en avais tellement j'avais enregistré
tellement de radios libres que ça y
avait des médecins pour faire un disque
historique y at il de plus fugitif que
la radio et télé grâce à nos disques
bombardant le côté archiviste finalement
autant bouquin c'est ce à quoi c'est un
boulot de
de recherche oui absolument aussi
l'assurance que dire quand et comment
quelqu'un de très éclectique tellement
éclectique à la limite tu deviens
incernable
tu peux très facilement être ta petite
utilité est ronde et rubio il faut un
peu tous les papillons de temps en temps
pour faire un truc sérieux il faut
surtout montrer
un souhait que d'adressent que tu fait
sérieusement que les choses sérieuses
très sérieux ça s'appelle les ennemis du
système est ce que tu dis c'est qu'à
l'époque de la seule idéologie
consensus l'ère du vide il ya quand même
des gens sont extrêmement gens ne sont
pas d'accord avec ça aurait été un
archiviste fractionner les papillons jeu
les collectionnait les mouvements
extrémistes
j'ai fait un inventaire exhaustif tout
ça fait aujourd'hui en france veulent
détruire la société notre société
occidentale ne supporte pas le salir et
fuse ils ont tous deux souvent par
exemple quand on parle avec des
militants d'extrême gauche de jeunes
types d'extrême gauche française en 18
ans de la france 89
ils pensent que c'est une fausse
démocratie c'est à dire que la
démocratie apparente c'est purement
formelle mais qu'en réalité on des
manipulés il ya des gens qui tirent les
ficelles qui sait on va les prendre sans
va prendre les plus et plus
extraordinaires on va faire une
interview ce bout tu es prêt oui
alors par exemple que les maoïstes
prochinois des maoïstes et oui abcès
lesquels on va dire ça c'est tout ce
sont des gens qui étaient pour bas au
cas où étaient vivants un pic en mahomet
mort et puis que il ya eu les procéda
bande des quatre ils ont suivi ils ont
suivi le gouvernement ils ont dit les
chinois ont toujours raison donc si les
chinois se démène with 11 des maoris
dossier au fil comme eux et en fait dans
leur ces gens là évidemment aujourd'hui
le sens du temps de présence vers un peu
à l'image de la chine
mais alors là ils ont un petit problème
avec dennis yau pl non pas pour
l'instant ils sont plutôt du côté des
étudiants chinois et les maoïstes pro
albanel alors ça c'est que ce ne sont
plus maoïstes après avoir rompu avec mao
en 1977 est alors ils sont durs vraiment
dur dur nous ils sont alignés totalement
sur la politique de tirana et alors ils
ont une espèce d'international les
partis qui sont proches de tirana si tu
veux en france le principal c'est le
parti communiste des ouvriers de france
le pc ol et tu veux pour différencier du
pc être réactif que bien un journal la
rue ils sont très incertains dirigé par
l'ampleur journal s'appelle laforge a
tout fait
voyez risque oui oui et les maoïstes
invariants alors cela ce sont les plus
et plus peut-être les plus actifs pas
les plus actifs mais disons que sans
doute les plus dangereux c'est à dire
qu'il maoïste invariants sont ceux qui
continuent à adorer mouse ma mort il
continue quoi qu'il arrive ils sont bas
où il se vend le problème c'est que ces
gens-là ont été beaucoup vécu et la
plupart des mouvements qui se réclament
du terrorisme se réclame à maui sma
variole donc si tu veux ça dans cette
espèce de moules
on peut mettre par exemple certains
certaines tendances d'action directe on
peut mettre les brigades rouges on peut
mettre également les cellules
communistes combattantes belge alors
évidemment c'est ce qui s'est passé pas
mené à l'essai ccbc du communisme
combattants et c'est ce qui tue les
généraux de l'otan constamment entre
autres mais juste comme ça donc là ça
devient assez inquiétant d'autant plus
qu'ils se greffent là dessus une
nouvelle catégorie de maoïstes qui sont
les partisans européen du sentier
lumineux du pee wee alors cela sont
évidemment ce sens elle doit aller plus
alors à l'extrême-gauche y abondent
c'est un petit peu comme ça il ya la
vieille taupe c'est à dire des gens qui
bien qu'à l'extrême gauche on sent
proche des pro nazi dans la négation des
chambres à gaz or ça s'est très vite ça
c'est de nouveau un groupe très
particulier c'est un courant très
particulier effectivement alors ce sont
des militants ultra gauche
ouais c'est à dire un courant alors il
faudrait vraiment faire c'est très
compliqué mais bas ce qui aurait
compliqué mais quand on lui tombe bien
comprendre c'est à dire que moi ça me
passionne personnellement lui alors donc
en fait ce sont des gens qui sont
marxisme et pas léniniste et qui si tu
veux sans doute que la variance absolue
et d'une intransigeance absolue et qui
on ne sait pas pourquoi ont décidé
qu'ils étaient les seuls à voir clair
dans ce monde et ont décidé qu'il y
avait un autre mec qui voyait clair que
c'était faurisson
qui nie l'existence des chambres à gaz
alors ça évidemment le petit romantisme
à tourner vite à la tragédie dire
qu'aujourd'hui à des groupes donc ultra
gauche comme la vieille taupe et le
actives dans ce domaine là qui est
tellement convaincu que le génocide n'a
pas eu lieu pendant les deux guerres
mondiales que ils sont prêts à passer
des accords avec les mouvements
d'extrême droite il ya le cercle
national des français juifs
oui c'est à dire que c'est l'échec
notion au front national oui suivant
c'est quoi ça passé
très peu non et alors le cercle national
des français juifs s'est plu à tous
petits groupuscules qui est
effectivement il est censé regrouper les
quelques juifs du front national qui
suivent la ligue le front national ce
qui est toujours un peu délicat mais
alors ça c'est à dire ce qu'a réalisé
sur eni et alors il ya des néonazis qui
s'appelle le club des surhommes et sans
combien je crois que 2,4 peu avant des
biens finis il y en a pas mal
il y en a énormément par exemple qui
sont adhérents du front national a
énormément mais eux ils se réunissent
par exemple l'année dernière il son
regard l'otage en 12,5 et alors ils
avaient des grandes banderoles travail
famille patrie
il y avait des écrivains qui sont
fabriqués un pétainiste il tempêté
nistos pu faire la différence alors l'un
sur le travail l'eau sur la famille
l'autre sur la patrie à l'horizon des
journaux et tout mais alors le 30
problème des pétainistes qui se
déchirent entre eux ah oui il ya deux
associations membres manière oui ce
samedi à nantes et à venir qui serait
donc la rue accord lui trop dépitée qui
se ne sais pas
et alors il ya des nationalistes de
gauche en fait c'est les nationalismes
pro soviétique
oui alors ça tu vois c'est bon il ya un
tel en france il ya un tel spectre de
groupuscules tellement étrange de
mouvement tellement spéciaux qui
effectivement aujourd'hui des militants
d'extrême droite qui estime que
finalement le plus grand danger qui
menace l'europe c'est l'américanisation
bisous la coca cola culture et c'est
donc en fait il ya un état fort en ce
moment en europe et c'est l'union
soviétique
donc ils sont pour effectivement une
alliance militaire entre l'europe
occidentale et l'union soviétique et à
terme il pense effectivement que après
tout faut pas oublier que le
les militants d'extrême droite but pour
un état fort alors maintenant c'est pas
du tout une conception communiste mais
malgré tout l'union soviétique c'est un
état très fort si tu devais choisir
oui entre tous ces groupuscules que tu
décris bien pour moi j'adhère et
certainement pas parce que moi ce qu'il
était obligé au bout non mais justement
non puisque mon grand bonheur c'est que
je n'ai jamais adhéré depuis que j'ai 10
ans je ramasse les trappes et pour être
sûr de ne rien rater de l'inaptitude
abonnez vous mettez un pouce bleus